plant yourself down and pour yourself
some tea because it's episode 9 of the
chilling Adventures of Sabrina and this
one's out of this world
last episode ended on an ominous note
with a knocking at the King Cole's door
could it be Tommy returned from the dead
or worse Harvey opens the door and oh
it's just Sabrina she's just casually
checking in to see if any zombies might
have dropped by lo and behold Harvey's
elated as Tommy's back but due to all
the trauma from the collapse he's not
really eating or talking or anything at
home Ambrose has bought some sweet new
duds for his first day working for
Blackwood who's currently freshening up
after an evening of kinky flagellation
with Zelda Faustus a Selda to keep quiet
about this says lady Blackwood isn't
quite as fond on cheating as he is which
of course would be a horrible influence
for his twin sons
yes Zelda if she'd like to be their
unholy godmother or Knight mother and
also take over Lady Blackwood's classes
at the academy and Zelda's like Sabrina
fills Ambrose in on everything that's
happening with Tommy the doctor says
he'll be fine in a few days but Ambrose
isn't satisfied by any doctor's opinion
unless it's a witch doctor meanwhile
it's bedtime at the academy and the
young witches are reciting the Dark
Lord's Prayer which seems to be the
opposite of the Lord's Prayer as she
recites prudence notices Agatha having a
tough time existing before she pukes out
some dirt after Sabrina's shower Nick
astral projects in and wait a minute how
long were you watching her for Nick
let's Sherlock this I have new evidence
to submit to the court in episode 4
Ambrose has enough time to astral
project to his date and be early have
war well snoop around the Spellman's for
a while and wait for Luke to arrive and
start a conversation before even one
psychopomp shows up meanwhile Nick
arrives and there's immediately a pump
in the window he would have been there
for at least five minutes ergo you were
totally perving on Sabrina in the shower
weren't you Nick to leave he also let
Sabrina know Agatha's coughing up gravel
at the King Cole's harvey catches Tommy
scratching up the mirrors in the dark to
try and help jog his memory Harvey shows
his brother an old family album but the
only thing he seems to respond to is his
old football photo at Suzie's Dorothy
has appeared to her once more goading
her into some mischief before dad comes
in hearing voices
the
next morning Hilda gets the call that
the miners bodies have been found and
are going to be sent over for autopsy
won't be long before he'll then Zelda
find out about Sabrina's night of
necromancy Zelda and Ambrose are also
heading out their first day at the
academy
Sabrina returns the Book of the Dead but
it's caught by miss ward well she plays
coy with Sabrina and lets her know she
can borrow anything she'd like from her
office if she asks what a pal in the
hall Roz rushes up to Sabrina as the
news has come out Tommy's alive and Ross
has had a cunning dream about him she
was in the woods and it was snowing when
she spots three dogs chewing apart
Tommy's carcass
this gives Sabrina the idea to bring Roz
to Tommy to try to figure out what's
going on with him Ambrose starts his
first day at the academy in Blackwood's
office with Luke there and is it me or
what why does Luke look always so damn
evil all the time I don't trust you man
I don't trust you but who cares ambrus
gets a pet mouse ah a familiar of his
own name Leviathan a cheeky little name
considering a Leviathan is a giant sea
monster Blackwood is gaining Ambrose is
loyalty as he'll need his help on a
mission to reform the rules of the
Church of Knight and Luke and Ambrose
get to work unfortunately they're
interrupted by the weird sisters
featuring pervo Nick who hope Ambrose
might know something about what's
happening to Agatha she's gotten worse
now she's coughing up turnips at doctor
services Susie's doing a little
shoplifting Dorothea's idea no doubt
before being confronted by the football
Bros for a little bullying luckily Hilde
is there to save the day and tell the
boys their deepest darkest secrets
including bully number two who's in love
with a ringleader when he'll the spots
the book Susie goes running the book she
was stealing was Orlando by Virginia
Woolf considered a feminist classic it
depicts the adventures of a poet who
changes sexes from man to a woman and
lives for centuries meeting the key
figures of English literary history
Hilda gets a call from Ambrose and goes
to check up on Agatha she reckons Agatha
has too much earth in her and prescribes
fizzy water with cayenne pepper to
balance out the elements of course this
is all bull to prevent them from
freaking out the grim reaper is pissed
that Agatha was revived and now it means
to collect Sabrina brings rose to visit
Tommy who's just staring at a tree
Tommy is nonreactive to everything with
a few exceptions including a football
throw will later learn that Tommy's
without a soul it's law
stand limbo and my guess is that all his
husk of a body can do is react a muscle
memory like how he used to be a star
football player inside Ross uses her
cunning on Tommy and enters a misty
realm with the sounds of crying babies
as she catches a glimpse of Tommy in the
distance she's interrupted by a woman
who appears as some sort of corrupted
creature with a noose around her neck
mr. kinkle gets home and that's always
good news
dad they were hoping like they know more
than dr. Phibes
really they can't come over and help
your son maybe watch him for a bit and
feed him or something yeesh I'm so done
with this dude
Roz needs to cunning this fool the seal
put a stick up his back at Suzy's she
goes over the events at dr. services
with Dorothea she mentions hilda and
Dorothy asks if the Spellman's are still
witches meanwhile Sabrina accidentally
spills the beans about Tommy to Hilda
who's all I'm not mad I'm just
disappointed
oof hate that one but Sabrina still
believes she can save Tommy as his soul
is lost in limbo an area of the
afterlife in between Heaven and Hell
where you go if you died before your
time
or you're an unbaptized baby all she
needs to do is get there and retrieve
him he'll the states that's impossible
as Tommy's in mortal limbo and no witch
can enter luckily for Sabrina she's half
mortal but the longer Tommy lives the
closer Agatha gets to death there must
be balance at Darkly Club Zelda looks to
impress Blackwood with the cheery
rendition of doremi from The Sound of
Music
unfortunately they get interrupted by
Agatha who's ready for her solo now that
she's pooped out more dirt Blackwood is
furious and heads out to kill Tommy and
restore the balance
Zelda stomps him and begs Faustus to let
her take care of it to try and save face
as Sabrina's her niece her
responsibilities in the mortuary Ambrose
shows hilda and Sabrina bite marks found
on the dead miners bodies human bite
marks Tommy hasn't eaten since he's
returned because he's already full at
least for now and we're back to this
dirtbag who's now drunk and yelling at
his non-responsive son when Harvey
pushes his dad and gets a punch in
return
Tommy's muscle memory kicks in once more
this time using its reflex and
protecting Harvey
Sabrina shows up with some mysterious
water that will put Tommy to sleep and
prevent him from chewing up Harvey when
she gets home Zelda is waiting for her
and boy oh boy is she pissed the whole
argument
that follows is about how Sabrina's
messing with nature and people's lives
both witch and mortal and how Sabrina is
going to fix it and bring Tommy back and
pause pause is anyone else on Team Zelda
here sabrina has totally messed [ __ ] up
get your revenge on the weird sisters
another way but you're actually hurting
Harvey more than you're helping him and
you're hurting your family too really
selfish the cherry on top of this scene
is this couch
stubborn as ever Sabrina pursues her
journey into limbo by asking help from
Miss Wardwell Sabrina confesses to
stealing the Book of the Dead and using
a resurrection spell and natural ward
well is understanding in an effort to
solidify Sabrina's trust in her she
mentions that limbo is dangerous and
that there's a monstrous Soul Eater
inside does she really want to go harvey
we do it for me in a heartbeat
which is Sabrina's motivation for the
whole thing Hilda walks in on Zelda
flagellating herself this time is
punishment she's distraught over
everything sabrina has done in the fact
she can never say no to her
she reminds her too much of her father
Blackwood recruits the functioning weird
sisters to go and killed Tommy King Cole
as he has no faith in Zelda something
Nick overhears so before the two get
inside the house Nick uses an old
witch's trap of spiking their footprints
to lock them in place looks like Nick
wants to see this one play out is it
because he's loyal to Sabrina and the
Spellman's or perhaps something else in
the woods miss Wardwell takes Sabrina to
a portal to limbo she ties yarn to her
wrists so that when Sabrina wants to
return she'll know her way back and miss
warbell can open the portal to pull her
out
Sabrina enters limbo with the same mist
and sound of crying babies as Roz heard
earlier dark figures wander about his
lost souls but none seemed to be Tommy
then a familiar figure appears Sabrina's
mom she too is lost in limbo remember
earlier when it was mentioned that limbo
is where you go if you die before you
were meant to the plane crash in which
Sabrina's parents died certainly seems
like it was no accident Sabrina's mom
ominously states they took her baby
after she was baptized there are still a
number of holes in the story of
Sabrina's double baptisms that have yet
to be filled but before we can learn
more in comes the Soul Eater in ensuing
chaos
Sabrina manages to run into Tommy and
grab his hand to rush him out but that's
the only part that makes it
ruh-oh Tommy's been so lean and he gone
there's only one more option for Sabrina
killer boyfriend's brother or whatever's
left of him exactly what Wardwell wants
finally severing Harvey and Sabrina's
bond
not to mention Rosa's cunning and
Susie's visits from Dorothea have shown
the two that Sabrina is a witch and they
begin to wonder if Sabrina is evil looks
like everything's coming up Wardwell
finally it's time for Sabrina to tell
Harvey the truth for real this time she
fills him in on everything the sleep
potion how she resurrected him and how
she's a witch
something Harvey now remember she told
him before back in episode 1 and
Harvey's sighting in the mines begins to
make sense to him and Sabrina too
finally she explains that what's in the
other room isn't Tommy at least not the
part that makes him Tommy
and it needs to go back in the ground
Harvey says he'll be the one to do it
and then after he won't want to see
Sabrina for a while you told my brother
you dirty rat Harvey then builds up his
courage and like a true King Cole
assumes the easiest and cleanest way to
take care of his brother is to shoot him
in the head that's gonna be quite the
mess to clean up before your dad gets
back outside Sabrina hears a gunshot and
it's done as soon as she gets home she
falls into Zelda's arms lamenting
everything she's done and her now
fractured relationship with Harvey and
Zelda just holds her comforts her like
the mother she truly is thanks everyone
for watching next episode is the last
and I'll be doing an ending explained
video along with the breakdown so be
sure to check that out and like and
subscribe see you all next time
on the path of night